[Applause]
[Music]
Russia's invasion of Ukraine is not only
radically changing Europe's geopolitics
security and worldview it also brings
huge changes for Russia and as time goes
on this will become more and more
noticeable in a recent video here on
visualpolitik we told you how the
sanctions on Russia are achieving many
of the goals they set out to achieve
in fact Russia is in quantitative terms
the most sanctioned country in the world
specifically 2023 started with 13 600
sanctions and restrictions of all kind
on the Russian State the country's
companies as well as many of the
oligarchs close to the Kremlin of course
almost 11 000 were imposed after the
invasion of Ukraine on the 24th of
February 2022. for the sake of
comparison Iran the second most
sanctioned country in the world has just
over 4 000 sanctions and restrictions
while Syria and North Korea have 2 600
and 2100 respectively
and that is not all Western economies
and in general most of Ukraine's allies
have made gigantic efforts to
progressively get rid of everything
coming from Russia it's gas its oil the
money of oligarchs everything except one
thing supplies from the Russian nuclear
sector
thank you
we are specifically talking about Ross
atom a huge industrial group owned by
the Russian government that for now has
escaped sanctions it has been spared for
one reason right now what this company
offers is much more difficult to replace
than hydrocarbons so despite the
enormous efforts zielinski has made
morning noon and night to pressure his
allies to sanction Ross atom as well so
far he has failed to do so Ukraine
expects EU to include Russia's rosatom
in next sanctions and keep in mind we
are talking about none other than
Russia's state-owned atomic energy
company and that's not all this nuclear
giant is virtually the only Russian
company that we can see is truly on par
with the best in the world and its
sector whether in terms of Technology
competitiveness costs or quality it's
something like the great exception of
the Russian industrial fabric a
productive environment that is to put it
bluntly characterized by its
inefficiency its excessive corruption
and a deep technological Gap with
respect to its Western counterparts but
you can see that this is not the case
with this company it's actually quite
the contrary of course the fact that the
Western nuclear industry has been
battered by the anti-nuclear policies
over recent decade AIDS has logically
contributed to Ross Adams gain in market
share but now then what is Ross atom
really what do they do specifically why
haven't sanctions been imposed on the
company and could this change in other
words are there grounds for sanctioning
the Russian nuclear giant what role does
this company play in the political
economic and Military fabric of Vladimir
Putin's Russia well in this video we're
going to answer all of these questions
and just a few more so let's get
cracking
foreign
Putin's golden child
as most of you already know the fall of
the Soviet Union was followed by a
period of several years of deep crisis
where a huge economic and Industrial
collapse was experienced and obviously
the nuclear sector was no exception
despite the fact that the Soviet Union
was a huge power in civil nuclear energy
for example it was in the USSR that the
world's first nuclear power plant to
feed electricity into the grid was born
it did this in 1954 the obninsk plant
with just five megawatts of power made
history but that was only the beginning
of a long road ahead since then the
Soviets have designed are built more
than 60 nuclear actors distributed
throughout the country and the rest of
the Communist Bloc made up of countless
satellite countries in this way they
gained significant know-how and a good
reputation at least until the Chernobyl
nuclear accident in 1986 then not
surprisingly everything changed but the
fact is that when the USSR collapsed the
entire industrial fabric of the state
also collapsed some of the traditional
Industries never recovered others did
but a much lower standard than their
Western company session and others on
the other hand were re-established with
Care by the government the latter case
was precisely what happened with Ross
atom
Vladimir Putin himself made a personal
priority to revive the nuclear industry
to this end in 2006 he enacted a law
that sought to create an entire
long-term strategic framework for the
nuclear sector and shortly thereafter in
2007 Putin himself founded Ross atom as
a state Corporation behind this decision
was the Russian government's concern
about the widening gap between
electricity supply and demand in other
words with Ross atom they intended to
solve the electricity shortage once and
for all and thus prevent it from
continuing to harm the economy in
addition during the 1990s Russia was
left out of the international nuclear
energy Market because it did not have a
reference producer to give you an idea
between the early 1990s and the
mid-2000s more than 100 nuclear reactors
were built around the globe Russia was
not able to participate in the
Construction and design of any of them
in other words Moscow understood that it
was missing out on big business
so as we say around here no sooner said
than done Ross atom was launched with an
amazing Financial Boost from the Russian
State and with Vladimir Putin 100
involved in the mission in fact it is he
himself who decides who runs this
company and who also makes the most
important appointments
the fact is that with this company
Russian nuclear energy has once again
made Headway and today it is already one
of the major international players in
the nuclear industry the fact is that
with this company Russian nuclear energy
has once again made Headway and today it
is already one of the major
international players in the nuclear
energy sector but to be clearer it isn't
enough for me to give you one fact of
the 53 nuclear reactors The Wander
construction worldwide in mid-2022 20
were built by Russ Adam and of these 17
were outside Russia in other words we
are talking about a market share of
almost 40 percent France and South Korea
have also been building reactors outside
their respective borders but they are
only involved in a couple of projects
each and it doesn't end there in many
cases the Russian company is also
responsible for the maintenance and
supervision of Russian technology
nuclear reactors around the world we are
talking about approximately 20 of almost
450 reactors in operation in other words
we can safely say that Ross atom and
little more than 15 years of operations
has managed to dominate the
international nuclear Market or at least
become the most important player in it
the Russians are hyper competitive no
one in the organization for economic
cooperation and development ovcd can
compete with what they offer Mark
Antoine director of the energy and
climate Center at The Institute Francais
de relation internationales surprised
well wait there is much much more We've
Only Just Begun
if you think about it for just a moment
the reason why the West has not
sanctioned Ross atom cannot be only its
nuclear reactor exports after all the
United States has no Russian nuclear
reactors and in Europe nuclear energy
has been marginalized for years and now
that is making a comeback most of the
nuclear technology suppliers are western
or South Korean not Russian so why on
Earth is Ross atom not being sanctioned
at once what else is in play for this
possibility to be completely ruled out
for the time being here comes perhaps
the most interesting part of this whole
story pay close attention to this
[Music]
atoms made in Russia
Financial sanctions restrictions on
technology purposes sanctions in Russian
gas and oil were imposed relatively
quickly however at the time of making
this video Ross atom has managed to fend
off any punishment or restrictions and
this obviously must have an explanation
right and it does this company not only
designs and builds nuclear reactors but
also enriches uranium
and although we can find major Western
suppliers here Ross atom is the world's
largest producer of enriched uranium
with about 30 percent of production and
almost half of the world's capacity in
addition it controls 17 of the global
nuclear fuel market and according to the
company itself 73 nuclear reactors in 13
different countries run on its Fuel and
we're not just talking about the former
Soviet nuclear power plants either in
2021 for example Ross atom provided
nearly a quarter of all the nuclear fuel
used by U.S nuclear power plants what's
more it is estimated that even in a
scenario as for players switching the
Russians will retain at least 15 of the
pie in the United States in the short to
medium term this is because it is a very
slow and costly process to specialize in
nuclear fuel production as a reasonable
scale and price
clearly it's market share in Europe is
not minor either
the Russians provide around 20 of all
the uranium imported into the European
Union behind only Niger and Kazakhstan
as well as 26 of enriched uranium in
fact from time to time the Russian cargo
planes can still be seen in European
Skies flying to countries like Hungary
or Slovakia with nuclear fuel thanks
precisely to the exceptions that were
introduced to the ban on Entry of
Russian aircraft if they carry nuclear
fuel they can fly freely but why is this
also important and is it really so
essential to keep Ross Adam free from
Western sanctions well the truth is yes
and it may not be exactly what you're
thinking take a look at this
[Music]
strategic influence
Ross atom is a huge company with a large
portfolio of contracts in the nuclear
sector to give you an idea in 2021 it
reported record profits of 20 billion
dollars so we're not exactly talking
about a small company and not only that
in that same year the holding company
atom or general prom that's really its
name in which a large part of Ross Adams
activity is Unified had a portfolio of
foreign orders of close to 140 billion
dollars to be executed over the next
decade and yes some of the nuclear
reactor construction contracts that
swell the huge numbers of projects are
in NATO countries some of them are even
supposed allies of Ukraine check this
out Hungary moves ahead with
construction of russian-built nuclear
reactors despite moscow's war in Ukraine
works at the Pax plant will kick off in
the coming weeks hungary's foreign
minister said Russia's rossitom signs
new construction contract for Turkish
nuclear plant the Turkish government
aims to start operating the first
reactor at the total 4 800 megawatt
plant before a general election next
year president tayyip erdogan has
previously suggested that turkey could
work with Russia on the construction of
two fervor plants so reactor
construction and maintenance is by far
the most lucrative business for Ross
atom
foreign
in fact let me give you another fact the
annual Imports of uranium and nuclear
fuel from Russia by the United States
and the European Union are essential but
amount to barely one billion dollars a
year yes that is a lot of money but it
is nothing compared to the nearly 200
billion dollars that were imported from
Russia in hydrocarbons just before the
war and neither does it come close to
what Ross atom earns from its reactor
and power plant businesses so with all
this you might be wondering so couldn't
Ross Adam be sanctioned to prevent it
from being able to build new reactors
and power plants while continuing to buy
uranium and nuclear fuel from them until
New supplies can be fully replaced well
yes it could and that would probably
hurt them the most but there are two
drawbacks
on the one hand taking this step in a
market restricted and with few suppliers
like this one might make Russia itself
willing to sacrifice those revenues in
order to leave the West without its
nuclear Fuel and this in the United
States and Europe could cause real
Supply problems for power plants at a
time of high hydrocarbon prices
[Music]
then there is another problem and that
is that there are not so many suppliers
of nuclear technology for modern power
plants in other words Banning Imports of
these Technologies would probably
generate a bottleneck of orders to the
Civil nuclear industry in countries such
as the United States France and South
Korea that would threaten the world's
energy Supply and it would do so
precisely in what is expected to be the
greatest period of electrification in
the history of mankind due to the
Fulfillment of climate objectives
something that by the way we have
already talked about here on
visualpolitik
so the reality is that like it or not
the United States and the European Union
will have to be very cautious about
imposing sanctions against Ross Adam and
that is precisely why Ross atom has so
far escaped unscathed now is this
irreversible well no of course not in
fact both the United States and the
European Union already have plans to
boost the production of enriched uranium
and fuel for power plants U.S redoubles
efforts to end dependence on Russian
nuclear fuel the White House is
prioritizing development of domestic
uranium enrichment capacity and
predicted key lawmakers will fall in
line so that a fuel manufacturing plan
can be entrained by 2025. nuclear
included in eu's repowering plan the
European commission has formally adopted
the repower EU plan which aims to
rapidly reduce EU dependence on Russian
fossil fuels the plan highlights the
importance of coordinated action to
reduce dependence on Russian nuclear
materials and fuel cycle services but of
course until all that materializes Ross
atom will remain of crucial import for
its Supply the risk now is the
dependence on the west will allow this
company to become a sort of bypass for
sanctions and divert Technologies Supply
purchases and profits to finance the
military campaign
[Music]
for the time being Ross atom has already
actively participated in the invasion of
Ukraine as that is the current operator
of the zapore's hazia sorry my Ukrainian
is a little rusty nuclear power plant
and also its de facto owner as long as
it remains occupied in addition the
company is acting on the orders of the
Russian government and operating this
Ukrainian power plant which is the
largest in Europe with a total of six
reactors since the beginning of the
occupation of the power plant units have
been switched on and off at the whim of
the Kremlin to undermine the morale of
the ukrainians and prevent them from
earning money through the export of
electricity to their European Neighbors
in fact this is one of the main
arguments used by the Ukrainian
government to demand that this company
be sanctioned as soon as possible but as
you have seen even in spite of its
collaboration in the war things are not
so straightforward in short Ross atom
rather than being a huge financial
Lifeline for the Kremlin which it also
is functions as a strategic political
pressure trump card it is the Red Lion
where unfortunately in this case Russia
does have the upper hand but now at this
point it's over to all of you do you
think the United States and Europe would
boot well to put their nuclear energy
production at risk and orders to
sanction Ross Adam could the company be
Putin's last great strategic asset
outside the battlefields well leave us
your opinions here Below in the comments
and remember if you like this video
don't forget to like And subscribe to
all of us here at visualpolitik so you
don't miss any of our upcoming videos
and remember you can help us grow and
improve by joining our community on
patreon we'll leave the link below once
again thanks very much for watching take
care and I'll see you next time
[Music]
foreign